en france 24 es momento de hablar de
ciencia y tecnología
soy valentina torre sánchez y es un
gusto acompañarlos iniciamos este
espacio en estados unidos donde el
laboratorio moderna solicitó a las
autoridades sanitarias la aprobación
total de su vacuna contra el cob y 19 y
se convierta en la segunda empresa en
requerir la luego de facer que hizo la
petición a principios de mayo recordemos
que hasta el momento todas las vacunas
que se están suministrando han recibido
una autorización de uso de emergencia en
eeuu es emitida por la administración de
medicamentos y alimentos en la unión
europea' por la agencia europea del
medicamento y en cada país por las
autoridades competentes pues una
autorización total toma mucho más tiempo
y requiere de análisis más complejos
pero permite que los laboratorios vendan
su vacuna directamente a los
consumidores y que el fármaco siga en el
mercado una vez que sea controlada la
emergencia por la pandemia
tradicionalmente la licencia plena para
un medicamento del tipo de las vacunas
suele tomar alrededor de un año y se
solicitan datos clínicos no clínicos y
de fabricación
se necesita un consolidado de
información sobre seguridad y
efectividad durante al menos seis meses
lo que significa que el fármaco siga
protegiendo a las personas activamente a
seis meses de haber recibido las dosis
necesarias pues modernas ya solicitó esa
licencia total para su vacuna en
personas de más de 18 años y fisher hizo
lo mismo el 7 de mayo para personas de
más de 16 años así como algunas naciones
cuentan con los protocolos sanitarios
establecidos para generar estas
aprobaciones hay otros países que
carecen de estos recursos y lo que hacen
es ceñirse a las autorizaciones emitidas
por la organización mundial de la salud
que justamente aprobó una 8º vacuna para
uso de emergencia habitual and that's
i'm all back me complace anunciar que la
o ms ha dado su licencia de uso de
emergencia a la vacuna corona back de
sinovac tras comprobar que es segura
efectiva y su calidad está asegurada
tras dos dosis de la vacuna inactivada
los sencillos requerimientos de
almacenamiento de corona bach la hacen
apropiada para entornos de bajos
recursos
octava cuna que recibe la autorización
de uso de emergencia de la oms
cif y bailables recordamos que hasta el
momento las vacunas aprobadas para uso
de emergencia por la organización
mundial de la salud son lado de facer
bayón tech la de astrazéneca fabricada
en corea del sur la de astrazéneca
fabricada en india y la de us
transgénica fabricada en europa que pese
a ser el mismo fármaco se consideran
como distintas la jansen del laboratorio
johnson and johnson la de moderna la del
laboratorio chino sino farm y corona
back de sinovac
continuamos hablando de vacunas y
puntualmente de la inoculación de
adolescentes y niños se trata de una
propuesta que no está exenta de
controversia para una parte de la
comunidad científica no habrá inmunidad
de rebaño hasta que los menores estén
inmunizados además aseguran que es una
percepción errada pensar que los niños y
adolescentes no se están contagiando con
el virus show de aksu y la lluvia los
niños se contagian se enferman y mueren
hemos visto más de 3 millones y medio de
niños contagiados en eeuu miles de
hospitalizaciones y entre 300 y 600
fallecimientos intrínsecas
jankovic 19 actualmente está entre las
10 primeras causas de muerte infantil
desde que inició la pandemia así que
aunque las cifras suenan bajas realmente
son altas respecto al número total de
muertes de menores de 18 años
sin embargo para otra parte de la
comunidad científica más que innecesario
es menos urgente vacunar a menores por
lo que piden a los países que tienen a
su población adulta inmunizada
que donen las dosis a naciones que no
tienen los recursos para adquirirlas
no sólo es que muy pocos menores
enferman y muy muy pocos mueren de cogam
vida también es que hay dosis limitadas
de vacunas actualmente y esos
suministros tienen que ir dirigidos a
prevenir muertes hospitalizaciones y en
últimas a prevenir la transmisión de la
enfermedad entre la gente
preventing transmisiones de infección
cuiden del population seguimos hablando
de kobe 19 pero vamos a tailandia para
conocer a jewel bobby y bravo tres
labradores que han sido entrenados para
identificar a pacientes con el virus
consuelo leerlos
se trata de una nueva estrategia de las
autoridades tailandesas en su lucha
contra el coronavirus ellos aseguran que
estos perros reconocen el cover en el
sudor de las personas a los adultos
mayores les preocupan las pruebas por
ejemplo con los hisopados nasales les
preocupa el dolor y les da miedo el
procedimiento ahora tenemos esta opción
simple
pueden poner una bola de algodón en sus
axilas para recolectar una muestra y la
enviamos al laboratorio donde los perros
dan un resultado muy preciso los
ancianos dicen que es muy conveniente y
les podemos ayudar a recolectar las
muestras así que están dispuestos a
hacer la prueba para entrenarlos a los
perros se les puso a oler muestras
contenidas en recipientes exactamente
iguales y una vez que identificaban el
cojín 1960 van frente al contenedor con
lo que conseguían un premio según los
responsables los canes han estudiado más
de 1.000 muestras y en un futuro cercano
serán muchos más los que reciban el
entrenamiento
y finalizamos en egipto donde omar abdel
salam crea unas gafas que con
inteligencia artificial traducen sonidos
al lenguaje de señas están diseñados
para ayudar a personas con problemas
auditivos pues reproducen el lenguaje de
señas lo que dice una persona gracias a
una pequeña pantalla incorporada las
gafas también son capaces de tomar una
foto de una página que vea el usuario y
traducir lo que está escrito al lenguaje
de señas se trata de un prototipo pero
su creador busca encontrar los fondos
suficientes para que sean producidos en
masa
así llegamos al final de este espacio a
ustedes gracias por su sintonía y
recuerden que pueden repetir este y
otros programas en nuestra web france24
puntocom
[Música]